الزلازل اعطى الكوارث الطبيعيه واكثرها
ضررا على البشر لم يستطع الانسان مواجهتها
على مدار التاريخ لكن على الاقل عمل على
تخفيف اثارها وكان للتكنولوجيا الدور
الابرز في هذا الشهر الحمايه من الاثار
المدمره للزلازل تاتي في قمه اولويات
العلماء والمهندسين المعماريين نظرا لعدم
القدره حتى الان على التنبؤ بمكانها او
بتوقيتها
التجارب الحديثه في البناء توصلت الى ان
المنشات المصممه والمنفذه بالشكل الصحيح
لديها القدره على مقاومه الزلازل العنيفه
دون انهيار
اليابان مثلا اعتمدت قوانين بناء صارمه
لاجبار المهندسين على انشاء هياكل مقاومه
للزلازل منها قانون تايشين الذي يفرض حدها
ادنى لسمكه الاعمده والجدران وقانون سيشن
الخاص بالمباني الشاهقه الارتفاع والذي
يلزم البنائين بوضع طبقات من المطاط اسفل
الاساس الامتصاص الصدمات الناتجه عن
الزلازل وقانون منشن حيث يتم بناء الهيكل
نفسه بشكل معزول عن الارض بواسطه الرصاص
والفولاذ
هذه القوانين ساهمت بشكل كبير في الحد من
التاثير المدمر للزلازل ففي عام 2018
تعرضت مدينه اوساكا لزلزال قوي لكنه لم
يسفر الا عن ثلاثه قتله ومئتي جريح فقط
وعلى فرض ان التكنولوجيا الحديثه عجزت في
الوقايه من خطر الزلازل عمل العلماء على
ابتكار وسائل حديثه للبحث عن الضحايا تحت
الانقاذ وانتشالها ومنها الاعتماد على
روبوتات حديثه
هذا الروبوت الياباني مثلا صمم على شكل
انسان يمتلك اذرعا طويله ما يمكنه من حمل
البشر ورفع بقايا المباني المنهاره
وهناك ايضا روبوتات صغيره بحجم الحشرات
تستطيع النفاذ داخل الاماكن التي يستحيل
على البشر الدخول اليها
هناك ايضا بعض الابتكارات التي ركزت على
ابتكار اسره نوم قادره على الحفاظ على
حياه الانسان في اوقات الزلازل والكوارث
الوسائل التكنولوجيه الحديثه كان لها دور
كبير في العثور على ناجين تحت الانقاض
اثرى الزلزال الاخير في تركيا وسوريا ورغم
ان الوصول الى الخطر الصفري يستحيل مع
كارثه الزلازل الى ان دور التكنولوجيا
يساهم في تخفيف الضرر وتسريع عمليه البحث
عن الناجنه وانقاذهم